is it true that you originally didn't
even want to do acting that you wanted
to be a doctor i didn't know this no
that is i never heard about that
me too i was i was going to be a doctor
too really and then i was like i guess
i'll see
like that's amazing hey that doesn't
wait no that's amazing not many people
are like i'm going to be a doctor that's
amazing
yeah well my father's a doctor my
brother was in oh okay so
from nowhere no not at all i found it
fascinating i mean i loved biology i
took honors biology i was like well this
is it for me first of all that's cool
yeah yeah but um how did that
sift happen that shift yeah well this is
a little weird but um
so
i mean whenever i would come home from
like spring break or something from
college and i
lived in l.a and i'd be driving around
and i'd hear a commercial on the radio
for a sitcom and they'd be you know
promoting their best joke and it just
sounded like it was being like punched
so hard like well that's a different
thing and i was like oh
that makes me cringe and in my head i
would think oh my god don't punch it
like that lisa just remember throw it
away throw it away
and i went when you're in that position
and that was my first thought was like
yeah throw it away wait what
why would i
need to remember that and those kinds of
things kept coming up and happening like
david letterman and i'd see someone on
i'm like oh she seems so phony lisa when
you're on letterman don't be phony
and then
and then i went wait
why would i ever be on david letterman
you're creating the vision board in your
head i love that i just love the shift
so finally you leaned into the voice in
your head it was like don't do that when
you're on letterman i did and i needed
like a practical rational thing like you
know what you don't have kids you don't
have any responsibilities you can go for
this now i love that so i'm so glad you
did oh my god
i am too yeah yeah it was life-changing
um so you probably let your doctor
family down but it's okay um
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
[Music]
you